and I was I was scrolling through
Twitter the other day and I saw the
average cost of wedding by state and I
really wanted to point out how it's
interesting how the cost of weddings go
up more and more but the length of
marriages go down more and more and it's
so interesting because it's like the
less value Brides bring like we've
talked about this we don't bring Purity
anymore we don't bring youth most women
are not taught to be submissive so it's
like what what do brides really bring
nowadays not much unfortunately guys I
don't say this with like a happy heart
you know I just we got to be honest with
ourselves so the last and last Brides
bring to the table
um it seems like the cost of weddings go
up and up and there's actually been
studies that have come out saying that
the more the wedding costs the less
likely it is to last